antonio brown fascinates me because
for as much of a train wreck as he was
2019 and into the early part of 2020
he hasn't been right he hasn't gotten in
trouble there was that one weird thing
about throwing a bike at a guard shack
that bubbled up after he joined the
buccaneers but that went away
quickly and quietly he's got the pending
civil lawsuit
alleging sexual assault and rape which
is a serious accusation for which the
nfl could still
take action against him even though he
was never criminally charged arrested
there was never even a criminal
complaint but that's still hovering
goes to trial in december but the guy
has been a model citizen
and he was a key contributor at times we
saw what he did
what was it week 17 he had the big game
for the buccaneers when
mike evans suffered the knee injury on
that remember that weird slide in the
end zone where we thought thought that
the acl went at first on mike evans
chris godwin's there so it's not like
antonio brown is going to bump up to
number two on the depth chart
and russell wilson has clamored for him
in the past lamar jackson has clamored
for him in the past the packers made a
phone call last year reportedly
before antonio brown signed with the
buccaneers when you consider the fact
that he seemingly seemingly has turned
it around now tom brady may be
the main reason for that and maybe no
other quarterback can
get through to him whatever language it
is that it takes to speak
to the better angels of antonio brown it
may be that only tom brady knows it
but how could he not at least be
thinking i could have a bigger role
more money with one of these other teams
i got my super bowl ring
thanks tom it was fun uh
the other side of it too is to the
extent that tom brady's had him under
his thumb
you get sick of that after a while
there's only so much that you can do
and i just i until that deal's done for
him to return
i'm gonna be curious about whether or
not another team looks at his film from
last year
considers the fact that he's he has
been different than he had been is it
worth the risk
to make this guy your number two
receiver yeah i i mean
it's they're still good there there is
good
i mean i think they're their teams are
going to evaluate the film and go
okay yeah we can use them definitely but
like to your point mike if i'm antonio
brown
yeah it's cool and everything like that
but but i would think he wants to
further his career
be a real staple of an offense like
you're saying
and probably make some real money again
in his career
as far as like you know real wide
receiver money
i i mean i just don't think that's
happening in tampa you know
i don't again i can't sit here and tell
you that i think he's better than
scottie miller i can't
i can't sit here and just go oh he's no
there's scottie miller's really damn
good
scotty miller he's faster than antonio
brown he's got more of a deep thread
ability yeah maybe he's not quite as
strong and as good all around players
antonio brown that way
but to me i just i look at it yeah the
more that this goes on the fact that
they kept godwin
and everything like that i would go i
don't know why he'd really want to be
there
unless he's willing to kind of take a
team-friendly contract and he just wants
to be a part of a good team
and play with brady but i would think
there's opportunities like you said to
go other places where
he might be able to really make a mark
and really be a staple in a part of an
offense in a game planning way on a week
to week basis
there have been crickets from antonio
brown on social media since the super
bowl
um and and the the other aspect of this
as you get farther and farther away from
the end of the season from the
celebration the parade the tossing of
lombardi from one boat to the next
that spell that was on you wears off
whether it's antonio brown whether it's
leonard fournette
he could be the other guy who goes
somewhere else makes more money
definitely uh as this
as this process shakes its way out but
the longer
you are removed and the farther you get
geographically from that moment
the the easier it is to to go somewhere
else
and uh i don't know is antonio brown
still living with tom brady i don't know
that i mean the guy
to his credit after all the noise he
made in 2019 and the pain in the butt
that he was for the nfl for the raiders
for the patriots for everyone you got to
give him credit that he has found a way
to assume and maintain a low profile
chris and no doubt uh i i thought i
thought the guy was hopeless
i i and and you know that's the other
side of it too um and i mentioned this
recently on pftpm
i i was just convinced there was
something wrong with the guy for which
he needed diagnosis
treatment evaluation that doesn't excuse
anti-social behavior but it could have
been
fixed medically but then when i see tom
brady turn him around the way he did
it could just be that he's a jerk and he
needs the right people around him
to get him to not be a jerk and maybe he
has matured maybe he has figured it out
maybe he's gotten to a point where he's
just not a jerk anymore
and if that's the case i could see one
of these other teams wanting to take a
chance
yeah maybe you're right and that listen
honestly
i still think it would have to be a team
that has a really strong personality at
quarterback
you know i i look at it still and go no
you're
it's going to need you know you need
them a homes or a rogers
or a guy that is firmly entrenched even
josh allen where you just
like that kind of guy where you go no no
this guy's a stud
he's the franchise he's the boss here
yeah antonio you can come here and play
and he's gonna get you the ball and do
all that
but hey don't you know if you act a fool
or do something crazy
this guy's gonna be okay and we don't
need you all right and
and that to me if i'm a team i'd still
want that formula as compared to
well i'm fixing my offense my
quarterback's not quite proven
and not perfect yet that's a recipe for
disaster in my opinion so
we'll see where it goes but yeah we'll
keep our eye on it
well i'd like to thank russell wilson
yeah could i
throw to him no doubt aaron rodgers no
if aaron rodgers aaron rodgers may not
want to be
bothered with it not not that i don't
mean that in a pejorative sense
he just it's like hey you know i'm not
the kind of guy that tells other people
what to do
and that's another thing i have in
common with aaron rodgers got a lot more
in common with him than not which may be
why he hates me so much
but um but but it's it's you're right
you need to be in an environment where
whatever
switch flipped the right way it stays
that way hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports